we've still got a few weeks until the  Nintendo switch presentation so the  rumors are still flying I'm Tony and  this is your virtual GameSpot news  update Nintendo's Virtual Console  settles games up through the n64 but a  new Eurogamer report says it'll start  offering GameCube games with the switch  eurogamer's sights three separate  sources and the site has been right  about several switch details already so  fingers crossed Super Mario Sunshine  Luigi's Mansion super smash brothers  melee and Animal Crossing are said to be  the first games in the pipeline and  considering the Wii U doesn't support  GameCube titles at all they would be  welcome additions to the virtual console  Nintendo declined to comment on the  report but the big switch presentation  is coming on January 12th we'll learn  more about price specs and launch lineup  then to keep up with all the latest from  Nintendo in the meantime you're already  in the right place  you